so when we think of performance
nutrition is it far to say that players
can get all of their performance
nutrition requirements from food alone
or do we actually really needs to use
some targeted supplements as well the
majority of the things you need you can
get from food are we we always emphasize
that we take a food first approach and
supplements are just out there to
supplement the diet where we've got caps
whether that's for convenience there's a
gap that can't be met by food because
it's timing or travel or whatever it
might be or whether or not it is so that
direct performance and that's something
like beer alanine that's one of the
products that we use with a few of the
players that do a lot of repeated
sprints basically it just works as a
buffer so that they can go and go again
we use a Korea teams as well the
benefits of the football player is gonna
enhance our recovery strategies a little
bit or also help with repeated Sprint's
and that's of explosive power and that's
a real sort helpful strategy for us as
part of our recovery if you're preparing
towards a key event or a key game you
might choose to load up on it for a
matter of weeks and then come off but we
tend to go for a lower dosing
consistently throughout the season and
together continued benefit really